hello everyone I'm Dana Perino along
with Judge Jeanine Pirro Harold Ford Jr
Jesse Waters and Brian Kilmeade It's
Five O'Clock in New York City this is
the five
[Music]
let's start with this Manhattan D.A
Alvin Bragg facing intense backlash over
his unprecedented indictment of former
president Donald Trump and some of that
criticism is coming from unlikely places
Trump pleading not guilty to 34 felony
counts of falsifying business records
and tearing into Bragg in a prime time
speech after his arrest
I never thought anything like this could
happen in America virtually everybody
that has looked at this case including
rhinos and even hardcore Democrats
say there is no crime
and that it should never have been
brought everybody said this is not
really an indictment there's nothing
here
my lawyers came to me and they said
there's nothing here they're not even
saying what you did
a number of legal analysts questioning
the foundations of the case against
Trump calling it weak and an overreach
they point out that the indictment is
missing a key requirement that would be
the crime that would make it a felony
and some in the media also think the
case will struggle to hold up
what is the crime that prosecutors are
alleging escalated this from a
misdemeanor to a felony if I had to
characterize it it's disappointment if
this is the only Pebble that gets thrown
at Donald Trump uh it's a very small
pebble where's the beef uh as far as a
felony goes I talked to a lot of lawyers
yesterday and none of them Republicans
none of them Trump supporters and all of
them saying
this this is a little thin in terms of a
case that's being brought against a
former president it's a little
underwhelming but D.A Bragg is sticking
to his guns even as critics blast his
role in reducing most other felonies in
Manhattan
these are felony crimes in New York
state
no matter who you are we cannot and will
not normalize serious criminal conduct
we today uphold our solemn
responsibility to ensure that everyone
stands equal before the law
no amount of money and no amount of
power changes that enduring American
principle all right judge since as the
news of yesterday settled in and you had
today to think about it what are your
thoughts now
you know I woke up this morning and I
said maybe I missed something but I
didn't miss a thing as I said yesterday
it was just a bunch of papers that were
stapled together the the indictment is
insufficient on its face it is
insufficient in terms of the statute of
limitations if you look at the first uh
several counts they are in February of
2017 which is beyond five years I think
it's the first 15 or 20 counts are
outside the five-year statute of
limitations we don't know what the crime
is that they are complaining about and
we should I mean because an indictment
is supposed to illustrate what it is
that the defendant did and if it's a
federal crime Bragg doesn't have
jurisdiction to prosecute that and if
it's a State Crime which was the only
thing that Brad gave us insight into
yesterday when he was asked what is the
underlying crime and why did you wait so
long he said well there's a New York
election law well I spent about two
hours on the New York election law today
and it's clear to me that the New York
election law only relates to campaigns
for public office in the state of New
York he cannot try to bootstrap a New
York state election law violation to
raise this to a felony state election
laws do not apply to a presidential race
in addition to that it's selective
prosecution uh it is duplicitous there
are four counts for one act and
um you've got an intent that's in
question did he intend to do it that
being Donald Trump because he wanted to
keep it from his wife and family or for
another reason and you the main witness
is someone who's a perjurer per se when
he opens his mouth you have to assume
the guy is lying and finally this whole
issue of the the the the jurisdiction
and and the statute of limitations and
the you know the the factual
insufficiency there's nothing in there
that the that a defense attorney can
prepare for it's absurd and let me just
say one thing about Alvin Bragg who made
a fool of himself yesterday as far as
I'm concerned he said we cannot and will
not normalize serious criminal conduct
are you kidding people are being stabbed
beaten stabbed brutalized and murdered
in New York City by career criminals who
are being let out again and again
felonies reduced to misdemeanors unless
you're a republican this is a pathetic
man who is not connected to reality the
only thing that I have a great concern
about and that I'm wondering about is is
he not specifying the underlying crime
because in the event that his case gets
dismissed because if he's any kind of
lawyer at all he knows this is an
insufficient indictment is he giving
Georgia and maybe Florida the ability to
prosecute that crime that he thinks
might apply to them as well without
being barred by Double Jeopardy do you
know what I'm saying so that he could
basically say I'm not identifying it
until I absolutely have to in case the
judge dismisses this it'll give Georgia
and Florida a chance to relitigate that
issue that I haven't told you about
interesting and so Harold how about
Alvin Bragg bringing Republicans and
Democrats together to agree on something
well first of all I'm glad you're back
thank you I'm glad I'm glad you're here
at the table here it's been a while the
um so the judge raised this last Point
she raised yesterday and I I thought it
was a a very smart Point uh and we still
don't have an answer to it and I think
that the fact that you continue to raise
it uh is an important thing to do two
um I reread it too and I and and I said
yesterday and I stand by it I thought
there would be a little more than there
was but what I did note what I didn't
notice and I think it's important to
note and we talked a little bit about it
yesterday it's it's clear that uh Alvin
Bragg and his team believe uh that David
pecker uh the the American Media uh CEO
and the head of the National Enquirer
they owned the National Enquirer is as
important a witness as as Michael Cohen
is number two
it I get a sense that he believes the
underlying crime is the way he's going
to prove is that he believes that
President former president Trump
intended to mislead the tax authorities
in New York with the falsification of
some of the business records now we can
argue over whether or not that is a big
enough crime to indict a former
president but on the books you're
allowed to do that I stand by what I
said yesterday I thought there would
have been more here what I what I what I
wish would stop happening and I
understand those of us on television and
certainly the president's lawyers are
entitled to their opinions I wish the
threats and the attacks on the judge the
judge's family
Alvin Bragg personally and Alvin Bragg's
family that has no place in this uh and
I would hope that on either side that
that we would stop that I've seen it
from one side against the judge's family
which I just don't quite understand our
judicial system works president Trump's
lawyers will have an opportunity to file
motions to dismiss this and just based
on what you've said judge and I think
some of the things that that others have
seen in the indictment they may have
some grounds to do it uh and if they if
the judge decides not to dismiss which I
could make one could make an argument on
that side as well I would hope that
those who are against this case and for
the president will allow the legal
process to unfold and if the president
is corrected he's not guilty he will be
found not guilty by by jury of his peers
and Jesse flimsy charges
are sure to backfire right if you have a
flimsy charge it backfires and then what
are the consequences of that you sow
deeper divisions in a country that's
already pretty torn apart yeah way to go
Alvin the Democrats are convinced that
Donald Trump's a criminal that he's
guilty of murder rape Espionage you name
it he's guilty of it and they were
waiting for Alvin Bragg to tell them
what Donald Trump was guilty of
and he came out and he couldn't do it
it was like being there during a will
reading and they found out they were
being written out of the will
and they couldn't process it so the word
yesterday was disappointment they were
disappointed they didn't get the mug
shot they wanted they didn't get the
violence in the streets that they wanted
they didn't get the Handcuff shot that
they wanted they didn't get the cameras
in the courtroom they wanted and they
didn't get an indictment worth a damn
the Democrats are Driven Crazy by the
fact that Trump is innocent until proven
guilty so for the last six years they've
been trying to create a crime that he's
guilty of so Alvin Bravo give him credit
it was creative he takes a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars and chops it up
into 34 felony counts and then he
concocts This legal theory that has
never been seen in the history of
American jurisprudence am I using
jurisprudence correctly very well thank
you and no one can understand it so the
guy can't read a calendar also because
all of the counts
and the checks were written in 2017.
yep so let me understand this Alvin
you're saying she in 2017 was trying to
influence the 2016 election
I can do that math you cannot do that so
the case is falling apart Alvin Bragg is
a dumb man the jury's tainted the judge
is a Democrat donor and the charges
aren't going to stick and also by the
way he filed this thing Trump paid more
taxes
I'm a Democrat and I've said all along
you know what he's innocent unless
everyone is so I don't I nor was I
expecting this or apologies
National Review Dan McLachlan wrote this
piece that I loved it basically was it
said I will take these charges seriously
when the Democrats go back and take and
then he lists all of these things that
have happened in the past um that the
Democrats said weren't a big deal
I did not read that article
you on that kind of thing so I judge you
spent two hours in election law I did
two and a half so
do that to serve a couple of things I
think it's hysterical that whether the
timing was after the election or before
the election they think to kill these
stories uh was to Donald Trump's benefit
how many times have you said to yourself
honey get in the car but before we
decide who we're going to vote for get
the Inquirer and let's find out what's
in there and then I'll decide my
goodness if it's not the acquirer I just
don't know who to vote for uh so it was
unbelievable uh to flip around at the
all the channels last night and see
people just look at this case and no one
could get any traction I think it
diminishes all the other cases and I am
somewhat in all seriousness sad because
in every one of the other cases that are
up there more serious less serious Trump
has got a point and the other side has a
point right the the election Georgia uh
marijuana everybody's got a point
and you know how long it takes for these
cases to mature years so for the next
three years we're literally going to be
talking more about the cases than the
Border than Ukraine then the the 4.75
gas that's coming our way this summer so
the things that actually help our
country that need to be addressed we're
going to be focusing on these cases and
I think it's actually going to overwhelm
the primaries I'm very curious to see if
somebody's got a strategy uh to win in
the Republican party and beat Donald
Trump knowing he's going to be taking
all the news Cycles away from people can
I can I say one more this just something
I want to throw out the judge said he
wants to move as expeditiously as
possible how do you set a motion date
December 4th right this is April May
June July August September I mean I
don't have enough fingers for that
they're trying to push it toward you
know the uh primary primary yeah right
New Hampshire in Iowa and you know how
expensive it is to bring Donald Trump in
200 million dollars
Superman that's another issue at one
point that hasn't been made that I would
make is the example it sets around the
world is horrendous hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else